just a little more
all ready to go hey b
no not yet carol still needs to check if
militech left any ice in the systems
corporates haven't shown up in person to
report the loss no i think we managed to
keep him off our scent
we left the trucks with the big corpo
logos down by the raffin camp
which was almost as much fun as leaving
a bag of flaming dog [ __ ] on their
doorstep
[ __ ] made it look like it just came back
from a corporal war
tour nice touch
everything's fine clean as a whistle
and saul what about him nothing
for now we're staying out of each
other's hair
so he's not planning a family council of
course he is
he just wants to keep me in the dark a
while longer
hey it's rachel the uh
passion project bd oh yeah
what's up we've got a crisis on our
hands
let me show you the road stevenson's had
a breakdown
nothing any shrink can do about it can
you come here to the studio
just to talk to him
fine sure on my way he said he'll come
thanks v wonderful isn't she let me show
you the right i always wanted to take
one of these suckers for a spin
which is exactly how all those naive
gonks
landed at the front didn't even need to
be recruited
they just showed you the tech
go on hop in everything is set
[Music]
all right let's fire her up hold on to
your head
damn it
anybody get this thing up and running
earlier maybe you wanted it
give me a moment
[Music]
oh yes
it's not the latest model but mention
bob did what they could
what do you think
nice and cozy in here you steer directly
from your seat
all you have to do is jack it what no
knobs buttons
blinky doodads no none the impulse runs
directly to your cerebral cortex
in a sense the basilisk becomes an
extension of your body
it's like a mystical oneness
if it's so mystical and [ __ ] why the
co-pilot
extra support i'll tell you once we're a
bit further from camp
we'll practice
okay if you want full functionality in
an engagement
you need a second person to handle
sensory overload
one pilot steers the other handles the
gun
it's oddly pleasant you'll see
okay this will do fine
a dry run first i'll disconnect for now
doesn't need two pilots you won't be
steering and firing
are you ready
pan am is this uh it has designed
neural synchronization doesn't happen at
the snap of one's fingers
it'll be over soon there see
okay just don't understand what you
meant
warm up don't worry i'm not gonna watch
just put it through a few turns
soft ride
fly right over any now take her along
the line of turbines
when i say so swerve right or left
before the last of them
all right
left very good
keeper going
right
yes that's the way to do it
right
next
now let's do some shooting stop and i'll
activate this
what's on the menu don't get excited
the basilisk is a cargo ship by design
but it should still be a good time
all right blast those wrecks
good they're better than dirt now
okay practice is over
hey do you remember what i said about
impulses
well watch out now
what's happening hi jackson
our nervous systems are now linked right
basilisk pilots worship in harmony
that why i'm feeling everything
doubled it's sensory feedback
our systems are intertwined but would
you like to
try it out okay
i could go for that can you feel that
honestly yeah no idea how people can
focus in combat
it's probably not always this intense
how about this
um
[Applause]
ugh
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh we found it
we have to help the family
we're almost there
okay
hmm
is everything yeah congratulations
it's time to talk
all of us each on his or her own must
think first and foremost of what's good
for the family
come on salt if i have to leave the clan
please just say so
spare me another speech of yours at the
very least i'm afraid you'll have to sit
through a few more
because from this day forward you will
lead this family
by my side i will what i wish to do this
properly but fine
have it your way i was wrong
you were right that's the truth they had
never happened again
but i i i made a mess of so many things
you said i know but i changed my mind
you risked everything for this family
not even knowing whether you'd be
welcome the next day okay
okay well i
many things will have to change yes and
to start with we need to leave this
place
quickly we can't wait for militech to
find us
of course i will prepare our route
congratulations terrible choice i voted
nate
thank you thanks i need to cool down i
think
will you come with me
an interesting day
i feel as if i barely evaded a rapidly
approaching train
it's pretty close i don't know if i
could have done it without you
hey come on no i'm serious
good to know
nobody's behind the bar that i like
beer lemonade
beer me
to happy endings
what's gotten into you speaking of happy
endings
back there in the bacillus guy i hope
you don't regret what happened i regret
one thing only
but we had so little time guess we'll
have to do something about that
you know you know this
this could be us every day
v look around look at them
they could be your family pan am what do
you stay in camp
join us
i'd love to panty i really would
here comes that damned butt but
i can't not right now
have to finish some things first
all right v i shouldn't draw bombs like
that on you right now
i just thought uh forget about it
i'll think it all over i prom
out of the car
me
pan am i v
relax everything is okay how do you feel
where where are we
you passed out completely we took you
with us
where we moved camp you are safe
everything is under control
oh v
v you have to tell me what is happening
the blood you were out for hours what's
wrong
pan am i it's
getting worse every single day
okay b relax take it bit by bit
what is happening exactly
okay so
you ever hear of the relic the are a
sock attack
does something with personalities i saw
the ads
sounds like some rich people scam to be
honest it's not [ __ ]
i've got a bio chip in my head with one
of those constructs
and the chips damaged so take it out
definitely not that simple relics also
keep me alive
but so this is cyberpsychosis because if
it is i know people who no
the chip's data is affecting my neural
connections got nothing to do with cyber
psychosis
i remove the relic i die
if i don't deal with the construct i die
[ __ ] just trying to live with it
survive actually
it's certainly not doing wonders for
your health
i gotta go i'm feeling better
really
wait i will go with you i thought i
heard that voice
hey mitch finally we were worried
took good care of your ride she's over
there
but you're not leaving us already are
you is everything okay
thanks i'll stick around for a bit make
yourself at home
remember our offer still stands
if you need help the aldocaldos are here
for you then that at least we can agree
on
if you need anything you know where to
find us
darling i do not know for now i am with
my family
do not say that you know that i cannot
simply leave you want me to walk with
you you're a while longer
i am sorry too
great yeah her too i know this area
back from the old one
militech does not venture this far and
our vantage points really are much
better
but you know everything here it is
temporary
all of it we will soon have to decide
what comes next
v back to what we were saying
i will not even pretend to understand i
don't think it has even sunk in yet
but i am serious how can i help
honestly not a clue but there has to be
something
someone who can remember hellman
he's the one who created the personality
construct tech
that's why you wanted to get him but it
was a dead end
now i have to figure out where to go
next you'll find a way
and once you do let me know i will help
this whole family will help saul was not
joking you understand
thanks for everything for being here for
me
take care of yourself and let me know
well just please keep in touch